so before we get started I just want to
take a quick survey of the audience how
many people consider themselves to be
beginner JavaScript's okay a few people
how about intermediate level of
JavaScript errs now how about advanced
JavaScript errs okay you can come up
here and give this talk if you like okay
I'm just kidding
all right so what we're gonna do is
we're gonna cover a few things and maybe
not oh there goes first we're going to
get into the motivation on why we want
to write functional JavaScript and then
we'll look at some techniques and we'll
do some functional programming and code
examples so you get a better idea of
actually what this looks like so this is
not an advanced JavaScript talked i've
given those before and sometimes we lose
people very quickly and so this is more
introductory level so if you have a
question or if there's something in the
code like hey let's try this and see
what happens we probably will have
enough time to do that okay all right so
one of the main reasons I like coding in
functional style in JavaScript is
because javascript has a lot of edge
cases and nuances in the language right
this is what I call convection
convention overload and what that means
is as a software developer whether
you're writing code in C sharp or Java
or Ruby or whatever it may be we have to
keep a certain number of constructs in
our brain that are the the syntax and
the semantics of a specific programming
language right and unfortunately
JavaScript has a lot of these things
that we have to keep in our brain so for
example one of the rules that we have in
our code base is you never use a double
equals we always use a triple equal so
that we don't we don't get into trouble
with some of the bugs that are in the
automatic type inference that happens
with a double equals the triple equals
if you don't know does not do a type
change when it does the comparison it
looks at what's on the left and looks at
what's on the right and it says if
they're not the same type it doesn't
match right or they're not equal whereas
a double equal will try to do a type
coercion and change what's on the right
to be what's on the left and then do it
and that leads to a whole class of bugs
right so these things have been fixed in
newer versions of JavaScript so for
example in es6 we
we have proper scoping now with the let
keyword so you can use let you get
scoping within the block and you don't
get this kind of bleed or maybe bleeds
out the right word you don't get this
pollution of variables into the scope
where you don't expect them right so it
behaves more like other programming
languages but my point here is that we
have to keep all these things in our
brain while we're coding JavaScript and
one way to offload that is we use a
linter at development time so when
you're actually in the editor our linter
will say it doesn't matter which editor
you use almost all of them support like
real-time linting of your code alright
so we use a linter to help us say oh no
no you used a double equals you can't do
that in our code base right so those
things help but again you have to keep
these things in your brain which is
problematic because what is it that you
want to do when you're writing code you
want to focus on solving your business
problem you don't want to worry about
all this ancillary crap that's around
you
so anyways convict if convention over
loaned is an issue in my opinion most
JavaScript will tell you the same thing
and on top of this once you mix in a
framework like angular or react or view
or even jQuery or something like that
you have a whole new set of conventions
that you have to remember so all you
want to do is as a developer is go and
code your business problem but you have
all these extra things you have to keep
in your brain and I think functional
JavaScript help solve this specific
problem in a very nice way right so
we'll get up to speed on that in just a
second so you can do object-oriented
programming in JavaScript so I have a
longtime background in Java and rails so
when I first came to JavaScript many
years ago I was like well we'll just do
everything with objects it'll be great
it'll be just like the good old times
when I was developing code in these
other languages right but after working
with oo P and JavaScript for a while it
does just doesn't feel right and we have
things like typescript which allow you
to do and es6 also introduces the class
keyword which allow you to do
object-oriented style programming in
JavaScript okay so the the abilities
there and there are a lot of smart
people that I know who like typescript
and they think it's great and you know
with the static typing and everything it
helps you write more clean and polished
JavaScript code but what I typically
think of this it's just like no it's
still it's still very messy we're not
the
yeah typescript does a good job but if
you look at the transpiled code that
typescript produces or even what es6
produces like you know so you you have a
es6 project you use the class keyword
and constructor and blah blah blah and
then you go look at the transpile code
using babel or if using typescript they
have their own thing then it's like this
is kind of messy and yes there's source
maps to be able to say there was an air
here in a class and it maps back to a
specific line but it's like well let's
let's see if we can code more to what
the language actually has inside of it
and still be able to write a good code
base and that's where functional
JavaScript comes in and on top of that
functional JavaScript is currently hot
in many different areas so if you're
programming stuff in the react world how
many people react developers just out of
okay how many people were using angular
okay anyone using Batman j/s I'm just
kidding that's actually a JavaScript
framework but it's one of the more
esoteric ones but anyways my point is
with rxjs and all the stuff that's
happening in the react world around
applying functional techniques to
building front-end web applications
functional programming is finally
gaining some steam and a lot of people
know when we discuss javascript it has
two distinct parents in terms of its
language heritage so the the guy who
invented javascript was a little bit of
a programming nerd so he blended parts
of scheme which is a functional
programming language and he blended
parts of self which is a prototypical
object-oriented language and came up
with this thing called JavaScript
obviously it's evolved a bit over the
years but at its core it's still a mix
of these two languages now what's
problematic about the object-oriented
part if you allow me to beat that horse
a little bit more is that self-- is a
prototype object-oriented language
whereas if you're used to working in
Java or C sharp or even rails or Ruby
what you're what you're using actually
there is a classic inheritance based
object-oriented language so a prototype
object oriented
is actually very different than a
standard classic inheritance based
object-oriented like you see in c-sharp
or you see in Java or in Ruby etc okay
so there's actually quite a big
difference there even between those
languages
all right so let's get into the meat of
this with the functional JavaScript so
this slide actually could be used to
describe almost any functional
programming language right I could take
this functional JavaScript out out of
the bottom and I could put it closure or
Haskell or whatever but so these three
tenants apply generally for any
programming language which is functional
in nature
the basic idea when we write functional
JavaScript is we want to use simple data
structures and not classes we want to
create higher-order functions which only
do one thing and we generalize and reuse
those and kind of weave them together to
come up with the solution to solve our
specific business problem that we're
working on okay and we'll see this in a
few minutes and some code all right
so again we write simple functions that
operate on data structures and we try
not to mutate the internal state of
whatever that function gets as data
right so the basic premise is if you
have an array and you have a function
that does something with that array you
output a new array and leave the
original array alone and we'll talk
about why that's important a bit later
all right so it's also a style kind of
thing right so when we're writing an
imperative style of programming what we
have is the thing on the top here right
so we say we want to print out this
array so we say ok 4 4 equals blah or a
length plus plus blah blah blah print
out the array right so this is very much
like coding at a low level in my opinion
what we prefer to do as programmers is
write in a more expressive kind of way
and functional programming allows us to
do this what we prefer to do is say for
each thing in this data structure go do
this thing right it's much more
expressive it's more terse and it's
easier to maintain over the long term in
my opinion all right so the first simple
functional construct we want to look at
is something called a map and this is a
collection in go operate on it and you
get a collection out right we operate on
every element when we run a map
operation right if we look at this
visually this is what it looks like
right so we have a bunch of data at the
top we have our map operation or a map
function and we get a 1 to 1 or n to n
kind of input-output type of scenario
right so we often think of a map as a
transform we're transforming a data
structure in some way and getting a
one-to-one kind of right if there are 10
things in a right we run a map operation
against it we get 10 things on the other
side of it ok so and will kind of tie
this together and like you might be
thinking well this is all very academic
almost how does this actually I mean how
do you actually use this when you're
developing web applications right we'll
look at that a bit later if we have some
time but they're playing examples in
there the react role especially for that
all right so the second basic thing we
want to look at is what's called a
reduce
this is a ten to one sometimes can be an
end to M type operation so if we look
this visually it's also known as an
accumulator if we look at these views
visually this is what it looks like we
have a n number of things in our data
structure coming in and we'll get one
result out of it so a simple example of
a reducer is some function right so we
have an array of numbers and we want to
write something that adds these things
together and give us gives us a single
result ie a sum and that would be a
classic example of a reducer we'll look
at these things in code in just a minute
all right so let's actually jump into
our code editor for pretty much the rest
of this time and talk about some of the
things we've discussed in the slide
where so far let's make that a little
bit bigger all right so say we're
writing an application to program a
robot to make us some food which you may
laugh but that's not that far away
probably right so we could say we have
our raw ingredients here and we're just
going to use a simple library called
underscore for the time being they're
better libraries for doing functional
programming in JavaScript most of the
folks that I know have kind of
consolidated around using Ram DES for
doing functional JavaScript but we'll
talk about that a bit later
all right and the first thing we need to
do is we need to chop our raw
ingredients so we'll create a function
called chop and in this case I'm just
going to return that thing and prepend
it with chop so that we know something
has been done and the manual way of
doing this is we could say
up this vegetable that's in this array
and push it into our prepared vegetables
right right so this is obviously very
tedious and we don't want to do this
what we prefer to do is or maybe not
prefer but as a programmer we'll say all
right this is a perfect candidate for
writing a simple for loop so let's do
that right so we have our vegetables
here still have our chop function which
just goes and prepends this and we say
iterate over the array and push into our
prepared vegetables those things alright
so again this is imperative style
programming we are specifying at the
very low level exactly every little
thing that needs to be done to get from
point A to point B all right it's not
it's not very expressive what we prefer
to do is use something that is more
expressive right so when we think of a
map operation again we think of a
one-to-one right so if we were to run
this let's go run the previous example
actually ok this will take a second to
run and of course the font is really
small here at the bottom so I'll just
zoom in right so this is our output
loops right so this was our input array
and this is what we got as an output so
we're doing a one-to-one transformation
of what we put in and we get exactly the
same number of things out of it so this
to us screams at us that this is a map
operation so the other way we could
write this in more functional and
declarative style as we say underscore
map here's our input here here is what
our output should be or I'm sorry this
is the function that we're going to run
against each one of the things in the
input and we'll get out of it the output
and if we go run this this is not very
not very exciting but though it doesn't
work that's interesting
hopes if you spell right anyways I know
it does work but we'll come back and fix
up I don't know what happened here but
let's run again oh okay that's the what
was that saying in computer science if
you if you run the same thing over and
expect a different result that you might
be insane but in this case we're not
apparently so okay
I just ran again I don't know why it
worked but anyway so our point here is
that instead of doing this specifying at
a low level in an imperative way how to
specifically do with transformation
against an array what we did is we say
we said run a map operation against this
data structure using this code in this
case chop we could have inline that if
we wanted to but we typically like to
write things in this style where the
function is not in line with the actual
operation for clarity and for
reusability okay and we have prepared
vegetables that's our output and that's
what we spit out all right so this is
the first step to preparing our our meal
now we've cooked we've chopped
everything now we need to cook
everything in a pot so i've written some
pseudocode or it's actually real code
and what we're gonna do here is we're
gonna say alright so eventually we're
going to need to cook all these things
so we're gonna set the temperature and
I've just mocked out the actual process
of cooking something in the physical
world as a set timeout right you can see
I have some console dot log here but one
of the things that we need to do is we
need to take all those chopped
ingredients and we need to put them into
the pot and then we're gonna cook them
right so chop add to the pot and cook
them pretty simple making any kind of
stew alright so if we go look at what
are all add ingredients to pot does is
it uses that same imperative style to go
and put everything into the pot and
somewhere in here we're gonna have to
chop our ingredients and stuff like that
but actually we already have our
prepared ingredient so we've skipped
that step anyways here we're gonna say
add ingredients to the pot which is
called inside of here and then to go and
put everything together we're going to
say set the temperature set the duration
here's a temperature duration our raw
ingredients and we're gonna cook
everything in our pot like so so the
first we factor that we could do here in
a functional style should be obvious to
you we're gonna get rid of this thing
right here okay so instead of running at
this just make sure this works okay it
works down here let's see that your pot
is done cooking these ingredients
chopped onions blah blah blah blah blah
okay so let's go refactor that first oh
that's not supposed to show you it
alright so again if we go look at what
we were doing here we said for all the
ingredients that we have go add them
into the pot ie consolidate them into
one thing and so we're going from an N
number of things to one thing so that
tells us that we need to use a reduce
operation right we're going into one so
instead of having this array that's
going and adding everything into this
all ingredients data structure what
we'll do is we'll use a reduce function
we'll say reduce here's our ingredients
and here is our function and you can see
it does more or less the same thing on
the inside where it returns the contents
as it iterates and adds to that that new
data structure that we get outside of it
right now if we go look at the actual
output a little bit you can see that we
have oops this is not easy to navigate
we get the same result down here your
pot is done cooking these ingredients
etc etc alright and the way that a
reduce works is you pass it a couple of
key things first of all you pass it the
data structure that you're working on
and then you also pass it a function to
operate on in this case I've just
inlined it and the last parameter that
you pass it is the actual initial state
of that data structure that you're going
to return so in this case I have empty
pot we could just use an empty string in
this case and that would return that but
I think for the purpose of demonstrating
and reduce a little bit better or a
little bit more clarity is how do we
write a sum function for some numbers
using a reduce we
would say reduce this array of numbers
use this function the memo is the memory
ie what's carried over from the previous
iteration to the next iteration of the
invocation of this function and the I is
that specific thing as we're iterating
over that data structure so as we were
to go through this this I would be set
to one and then the second iteration be
set to to set to 3 etc and our initial
state or our memory in this case we want
to set to 0 right so if we go look at
the output here well no need to go look
at the output that is our basic kind of
deconstruction of a reduced function we
have reduce this specific data structure
with this function for each iteration
will carry over the memory from the
previous iteration for the first time we
run it it will be set to 0 and we return
memo plus I and this is our sum function
ok so this is how a basic reducer works
in JavaScript all right so for what we
did here again we reduce take all of our
ingredients in this case we're just
concatenate them into a string which if
we look here this is the string that
gets output and eventually added to our
data structure here and gets printed out
over here ok now if we look at this
we're going to move a little bit beyond
standard or basic reduce and map
operations and we're going to try to
attempt to do some additional functional
refactoring against this simple code
base so the first thing that I see off
the bat here is we're calling this
cooking pot thing we're setting the
temperature we're setting the duration
right here and we're basically just
invoking a function inside of another
function right so in this case what this
tells me is that I'm actually just doing
something really simple here I'm just
pre setting the parameters for another
function that I'm going to invoke and
what we can do in this case is construct
something called a partial so let's go
to that real quick
so we have our standard items here and
here's a reduce okay let's let's see how
we can apply partial to this case so we
have our old way of doing it where we
say okay we're going to cook this at
this temperature in this duration but
we're not really doing much else in this
case we're just setting pre setting
those parameters and passing that third
parameter in to our final function which
is cooking pot so what we can actually
do in this case is we can create what's
called a partial or what's known in
functional programming as a curry all
right and what that does is that says
you have a generic function but you want
to make it more specific by setting some
of the parameters in it and you want to
create a new function that's reusable on
its own so we're gonna reuse a low-level
function and create a slightly higher
level function in this case and again
I'm using underscores library here that
provides some basic functional
programming constructs in this case it's
called partials so they don't use the
keyword curry but they use the word
partial and what this does is that says
take this function call cooking pot
which if you remember is this guy right
up here cooking pot it's got three
parameters temperature duration and add
ingredient or or ingredients to add to
pot and we're going to say let's go and
preset the temperature and duration and
let's create a new function that is
based on this underlying more general
function so the the method signature for
this function would look like this right
for lack of better way of saying it
whatever okay and the reason for that is
in our function up here we have three
function parameters temperature duration
and add ingredients to pot and we say
create a partial on this function with
the first and second but not the third
parameter set so that third parameters
just going to appear as whatever
parameter is already there previously so
when we run this what this actually gets
run as is whatever we would invoke like
so actually I have it here at the bottom
I don't even need that okay so our
functional would be cook with these
final ingredients and these two
parameters are already set so you could
see I did this a couple of times here
just to give a little bit of an example
so I don't need to declare those
variables independently I can just
create them inline if I want if it's
something simple but you don't
necessarily need to do that or want to
do that depending on the use case that
you have here okay so this is what's
known as a partial or a curry in
functional programming okay so let's see
what else we can refactor here so
instead of having this thing right here
we can just get rid of this now say we
don't need this we don't need to create
this extra function we're just going to
base it on an existing function that we
have and preset these two variables and
create new functions so let's say we
would need it to do something else in
this case so let's say we weren't
cooking us two let's say that I'm from
I'm from Atlanta so we fried chicken
down there a lot we could say cook fried
chicken sorry let's get this right okay
and we're gonna cook this in a pot well
add some oil and stuff like that but
we're not going to cook this at 200
degrees well cook this more at 500
degrees because you got to fry the crap
out of chicken right when you cook it
and we typically will only need to fry
this for about I don't know eight
seconds there's not eight seconds well
be more like 80 thousand seconds but you
get the idea right so well what I've
been able to do is I'm reusing things
not at the object level but I'm using
things at the function level I reuse
functions to do specific things and
that's one of the biggest leaps that I
had to make when I went and started to
really do functional programming in
JavaScript is stop thinking of reusing
code as functions but start thinking of
reusing code as sorry
stop reusing code as objects start
reusing code as functions right so
there's a big difference there and how
we think about this these kinds of
things all right let me back out this
code so the next time I do this it's not
all screwed up all right so what other
folks
refactoring can we do here let's have a
look alright so we still have our final
ingredients we have our cooking pot as
we had previously okay so we did the
partial now the one thing that we can do
here is if you remember from the
previous example what we were doing is
we were cooking some stuff in the pot
and we were inside of that invoking
another function to go add our
ingredients into the pot on the inside
right so when whenever we see something
where a function is being invoked inside
of another function we can think of a
curry or we can think of something
that's called function composition and
what we do is we weave together two
generalized functions or two functions
which are more general in nature and we
weave them together in a specific way to
get a news function that does something
more specific and that's what this next
example does right so instead of having
our add ingredients to pot on the inside
of cooking pot we can say well it looks
like we're calling this add ingredients
to pot every time we invoke cooking pot
so let's create a new function that just
goes ahead and weaves those together in
this case what we'll do is we still have
our add ingredients to pot function
which we use as our reducer all right
we're still going to do this partial
right or curry but we're going to create
a new function here called compose and
we're going to use something called
function composition and we're going to
weave together this cooks to curry and
add ingredients to pot and in this case
what's happening is the functions will
get invoked from right to left with the
parameters which are passed in so this
is the equivalent of doing something
like this so let's create some space
here and we'll say I'm just going to be
lazy and say X right and this will get
invoked with final ingredients okay so
we have X and then our cooks to curry
only takes one parameter now because we
have a partial up here all right so
we're going to say
still using our curried method and we're
gonna pass it X okay if I can smell
properly there we go alright so a
Combinator or a composer that we have up
here right where we weave together add
ingredients to pot and cook stew the
equivalent of what we did there using a
composer is these two lines of code
first we invoke this add ingredients to
pot with their parameters that we take
the result of that pass it directly into
our next function and we invoke this
okay so this is what's known as
composition in this case we get a new
function out of it and if we scroll down
alright we were to not use this but use
our compose function that is what it
looks like so what we've done is we've
reduced may be reduced is not the right
word eliminated these two lines of code
which we would normally run and we've
created a new function by combining this
function with this function and creating
a brand new function which is obviously
a specific way that we're going to go
and execute this code okay alright so
this is what's known as composition and
and this actually comes in quite handy
like if you've if you at this point
you're probably wondering how does this
help with web development right it's
like okay that's great we have some
contrived examples here right but one
way to think about a composition is say
that you go and fetch a data set from a
restful endpoint and you want to go
populate a table right inside of your
web application alright one of the
things that you'll want to do is you'll
first want to take that JSON data set
just get the stuff that you want out of
it to show in a table so that's one
function right get me the data or get
data or transform data and then you want
to take that and construct multiple
table rows out of it so we can take
those two functions go get the data and
then go and create the actual of TR like
strings to put into an HTML table but we
can weave those two functions to
the other and then we have a brand new
function and we have something that's
reusable and that get data that we can
use somewhere else where it's like well
we don't actually want to show TRS in
here we want to show that stuff as
allies in HTML so instead of saying
generate table content we could say
generate Li content but still use that
get data that transforms the data and
gets it ready for us right so another
example of this would be say that we
need to apply some CSS stylings to a
table row again we can weave together
this function that says okay I have this
transform data now I'm going to attach
this CSS into the string to show it with
some specific stylings all right so we
think in terms of compositions and
reductions and transforms rather than
just working with standard
object-oriented data all right let's do
one more quick transformation and
hopefully this will help you understand
kind of how this can all come together
really nicely
all right so at this conference we have
we have non vegetarian and vegetarian
food but let's say we needed to write
some code that created both types of
things okay what we could do now is we
could say all right we want to reuse
this cooks to function as best as
possible but we want to create something
different we want to create a vegetarian
version of whatever our dish was going
to be or maybe even vegan all right so
what we can do in this case is we can
say let's go run a filter against the
final ingredients and only include
things which are all vegetarian right if
we look at that data structure here I
have our final ingredients I've added a
few things up here like chicken and I've
created two more bits of data here that
says what's everything that's vegetarian
and what are some non vegan foods let's
use those really quickly here and say
all right we're going to create a
vegetarian version of this and we're
going to reduce we're still gonna use
our composer to say add ingredients to
pot and then execute cooks do curry and
create a new function called at the pot
and cooked but in this case we're going
to say go and filter out everything
that is not vegetarian add something
that that is vegetarian into this and
then let's go cook that right but you
might say well I'm a vegan so we can use
a different kind of very specific
operation here called reject and say
reject everything that is non vegan push
tofu into that and go use this again
right so you can see we're reusing the
same function over and over by applying
a couple of small functional programming
techniques around it all right I'm about
ten minutes left and we want to talk
about the technique so usually I spend
more than fifteen minutes on that code
and kind of do some more examples but we
only have 40 minutes so what I'd like to
do is move on and talk about techniques
and in terms of applying this in the
real world all right so we try to focus
on data as much as possible when we're
doing functional techniques not so much
on object or building a domain like
doing domain driven development or
whatever it may be we try to think in a
functional style as much as possible as
well and we use some utilities to help
us so we don't have to write all these
low-level things one of those utilities
is underscore all right so this is a
great way of getting started with it
most people are using underscore already
anyways it's a very lightweight library
and as you saw in our code it provides
underscore dark partial underscore dot
compose filter etc etc it is written in
functional style so you can use it you
can use something called Ram de which is
a more it's a much larger library and
it's a little bit more pure in terms of
how you use it to write functional
constructs in JavaScript but again this
is kind of once you've gotten past the
beginner stage I mean but underscore has
some simple operations as we've seen
before
so you can use in each to go iterate
over everything instead of using a for
loop right we typically prefer to use
underscore map and underscore transform
because those are more functional in
style but if you just need to iterate
over every to something
it also has nice little utilities like
you can go and pluck stuff out of a data
structure and say I just want the
speaker names you can say
underscore pluck from this sessions data
structure just to speak her names part
of it right we already talked about map
so underscore implements dot map as
we've seen before in our code base right
we've talked about reduce and as we saw
in our code to sample it supports reduce
as well and there are a bunch of extra
useful funks but what I'd like to do in
the interest of time is kind of skip
ahead to the going full on functional in
JavaScript or any programming language
all right so we try to use functions
function composition as much as possible
when we're coding in JavaScript ie we
try to write generic low-level functions
that we can reuse in different places
and weave them together either using
composition or sometimes direct
invocation this also leads us to what's
called a point free style of programming
and point free means that instead of
doing something dot something to invoke
a function we just have top-level
functions that we weave together or pass
into each other without having to use
points and we try to generalize as much
as possible to our basic way of working
with code is we'll write code once and
then we'll see how we can in the second
pass go and extract generic functions
and possibly keep them in the same place
or move them into utility library if we
feel that they're going to be useful in
other places as well
and we try to think of our application
as data transformations using pipelines
all right and we also try to use
functions instead of values so the
probably the next three slides are the
most important if you're not already
doing functional programming in
JavaScript these are the probably three
most important slides in this session so
when we think of the object-oriented
world whether you come from a Java
background or c-sharp or Python or Ruby
or whatever we tend to model the world
in our brain as objects what we prefer
to do when we're doing functional
programming is we prefer to model things
as functions so in the object-oriented
world what we do is when we think of a
problem we say okay we're building this
HR system
that means I need to create an
organization object that organization
object will contain a list of
departments and inside each of those
departments there will be a person
object but we want to subclass that
person object to be employee contractor
and manager right and that's how we kind
of approach a problem in the
object-oriented world and all those
things I said were nouns Department
person employee etc etc all those things
were nouns what we prefer to do when
we're working in the functional space is
we prefer to think in terms of actions
right so we prefer to think of those
things as verbs so we don't think of
okay I need a department object and then
person then we're gonna subclasses we
prefer to say okay I need to calculate a
person's salary so that was a verb or I
need to whatever right it's we think in
terms of verbs I need to add a person to
an organization that's a verb we think
in terms of actions rather than in terms
of the nouns themselves so that's a big
difference in that right and kind of the
core of everything here is that in the
object-oriented are the abstraction and
in the functional programming world the
functions are the abstraction we reuse
and build upon functions low low low
level generic functions and make more
specific functions to specifically or to
go and solve our our business problem
okay
so the functional world the functions
are the abstractions that's what we want
to think in we want to think in terms of
verbs instead of in terms of the nouns
all right nearly at the end here all
right
so and you might be thinking at this
point well how do we actually solve a
business problem if we don't model it in
terms of nouns
where's are all our data going to live
right but I build this HR system I have
an organization object that has a name
and an address and stuff like that and
would have a person object it's gonna
have a name and like you know the
identification number and all what do
you put all this data if you don't have
it contained within objects where does
that all go the answer is you can model
everything that you can do in the
object-oriented
in objects in the functional world just
by using two accommodation of two simple
data structures lists and maps so in
JavaScript that translates to arrays and
object literals that's all you need to
be able to model what you would normally
model in the object Oriental in objects
all you need is a combination of listed
Maps in the appropriate way okay so
let's look at a quick example of that
all right so what we're doing here is
we're modeling the lyrics for a song we
say the first line has these words
second line has these words okay so
instead of having an object that is
songs and then inside of that having a
array or a list called lines and inside
of that having an object called the
words right or you know maybe a list of
words or whatever what we do is we just
model it here as you see as a simple
list of maps or in this case an array of
object literals in JavaScript and now
what we can do is we can do some pretty
powerful things since we have it in this
simple data structure so our business
problem here is count all of the unique
words which are in this song alright so
the way we do this is we use the chain
operator and this is not purely oo right
but we tend to be pragmatic I'm sorry
purely functional we tend to be
pragmatic about this as much as possible
with saged first chain together all
these different things we're going to do
here's our original data structure that
contains all the words to our songs and
then run a map function that splits all
of the words into individual words on
each of the lines that we have we're
going to flatten this in case we have
nested arrays inside of it and just
create like a flat list of all the words
that are up here go and lower case
everything right because this is an edge
case we're going to hit upon because in
here you'll see that he's is lower case
here and upper case here and of course
those are two different words so we need
to go lower case everything and then
we're going to count up all the words by
running a reducer that says go do a
n2m so we're going to take a data
structure that's this big and we're
going to make a data structure that's
smaller that tells us we need to use a
reduce operation so reduce here's our
function right so the the actual data
structure that's passed down to here is
implicit since we're using the chain
operator what we say basically go and
see if the word already exists in our
external or what we're going to output
and set the initial thing to be
basically nothing or an empty array or
empty data structure down here and then
we go and spit everything out okay so
you can see that this is something that
you may not be used to in terms of how
you think about a problem but this is
very expressive and we can work with
things which are more more complicated
and more real-world like without any
issues and now there's some there's some
good reading on all this stuff and these
two are pretty good - pretty good books
here if if I'm having trouble falling
asleep I'll open one of these books and
start reading right so I'm only half
joking about that so one of the issues
with a lot of the books on functional
programming is they get very deep very
quickly and almost invariably the first
example they use to demonstrate the
power of functional programming is a
Fibonacci sequence right let me ask you
a question what was the last time that
you used a Fibonacci sequence to do
something for like real-world projects
anybody I don't even remember I think
maybe when I was like you know graduate
school in studying is like you know God
just math so I guess we'll use it for
Bonacci but anyways my point is some of
these books tend to get very very kind
of deep in esoteric very quickly so what
I would reference you to instead of the
two books here at the bottom is the two
books that are listed in text up there
probably the best one currently
available which is freely available
actually is a book called functional
light by Kyle Simpson and then once
you're ready to go beyond that and get
something get into some some really
really nerdy functional programming in
JavaScript there's professor frisbees
guide to functional Jas and both books
are freely available on github so if you
do a Google search
you'll find them pretty quickly alright
and I'm two minutes over time so I'm
going to stop I don't think we have time
for questions but if you have some
questions you're welcome to come up I'll
be here for a bit and discuss all right
so thank you for coming
[Applause]